nous devons rétablir des connexions saines entre nous.
Même le jugement sévère que j'ai en moi
envers mon frère et ma sœur,
cette cicatrice jamais refermée, cette offense jamais pardonnée,
cette rancœur qui ne me fait que souffrir,
tout ça, c'est un combat que je porte en moi,
une flamme au fond de mon cœur qui doit être éteinte
avant qu'elle ne s'embrase et ne laisse que des cendres.
De nos jours, beaucoup d'entre nous semblent croire qu'il sera impossible
d'avoir un avenir heureux.
Bien qu'il faille prendre ces préoccupations très au sérieux,
on peut inverser la tendance.
Nous les dépasserons
si nous ne fermons pas notre porte au monde extérieur.
Le bonheur ne peut être trouvé
que s'il y a une harmonie entre le tout et l'individuel.
Même la science - et vous le savez mieux que moi -
suggère que la réalité est un lieu
où chaque élément se connecte et interagit avec tous les autres.
Ceci m'amène à mon second message.
Comme ça serait merveilleux
si la croissance de l'innovation scientifique et technologique
créait plus d'égalité et de cohésion sociale !
Comme ça serait merveilleux,
alors qu'on découvre de nouvelles planètes,
de redécouvrir les besoins de nos frères et sœurs qui orbitent autour de nous !
Comme ça serait merveilleux si la solidarité,
mot magnifique, et parfois dérangeant,
n'était pas réduite au travail social
et devenait, au contraire, l'attitude naturelle
dans les choix politiques, économiques et scientifiques
et dans les relations entre les individus, entre les peuples, entre les pays.
Ce n'est qu'en éduquant les gens à une vraie solidarité
que nous serons capables de dépasser
cette « culture du déchet »
qui ne s'applique pas qu'aux biens de consommation,
mais d'abord et surtout aux hommes
qui sont mis sur la touche par nos systèmes techno-économiques,
lesquels, sans même s'en rendre compte,
placent les marchandises au centre de tout au lieu d'y placer les hommes.
La solidarité est un mot que beaucoup souhaitent effacer des dictionnaires.
La solidarité, cependant, n'est pas un automatisme,
elle n'est ni programmée, ni contrôlée.
Elle est une réaction naturelle qui vient du cœur de chacun.
Oui, une réaction naturelle !
Quand on réalise
que la vie, même au milieu de tant de contradiction, est un don,
que l'amour est la source et le sens de la vie,
comment peut-on réprimer cette envie de faire le bien à autrui ?
Pour faire le bien,
il faut de la mémoire,
il faut du courage, il faut de la créativité.
Et je sais bien que TED réunit beaucoup d'esprits créatifs.
Oui, l'amour requiert une attitude créative, concrète
et ingénieuse.
Les bonnes intentions et les formules convenues,
qu'on utilise si souvent pour apaiser notre conscience, ne suffisent pas.
Aidons-nous les uns les autres à nous rappeler
que l'autre n'est ni une statistique, ni un nombre.
L'autre a un visage.
L'autre est toujours une présence,
une personne dont il faut prendre soin.
Jésus a raconté une parabole pour nous aider à comprendre la différence
entre ceux qui prennent soin d'autrui et ceux qui ne s'en préoccupent pas.
Je suis sûr que vous l'avez déjà entendue. C'est celle du Bon Samaritain.
Quand on demanda à Jésus : « Qui est mon prochain ? »
en clair, « De qui dois-je m'occuper ? »,
il raconta cette histoire, celle d'un homme
qu'on avait attaqué, dépouillé, battu à mort et abandonné dans le fossé.
Un prêtre et un Lévite, deux personnes respectables à l'époque, le virent ainsi
mais passèrent devant lui sans s'arrêter.
Peu de temps après, un Samaritain, origine très méprisée alors, passa aussi.
En voyant l'homme blessé à terre,
il ne l'ignora pas comme les deux autres.
Au contraire, il éprouva de la compassion,
ce qui le poussa à agir de manière très concrète.
Il répandit de l'huile et du vin sur les blessures de l'homme,
l'amena dans une auberge
et paya de sa poche toute l'assistance nécessaire.
L'histoire du Bon Samaritain est l'histoire de l'humanité actuelle.
La voie des hommes est pavée de blessures
car tout est centré sur l'argent, les possessions et non sur les hommes.
Les gens qui se disent respectables ont souvent l'habitude
de ne pas s'occuper des autres,
laissant des milliers de personnes, des populations entières,
abandonnées sur le bord de la route.
Heureusement, il y a aussi ceux qui créent un monde nouveau
en prenant soin des autres, même de leur propre poche.
Mère Teresa a dit :
« On ne sait pas aimer, sauf à ses propres dépens. »
Nous avons tant à accomplir, nous devons le faire ensemble.
Mais comment faire, avec tout le mal que nous respirons ?
Grâce à Dieu,
aucun système ne peut annihiler notre désir de nous ouvrir au bien,
à la compassion, ni notre capacité à réagir face au mal ;
tout ça vient du plus profond de notre cœur.
Vous pourriez me dire :
« Ce sont de belles paroles,
mais je ne suis pas le Bon Samaritain, ni Mère Teresa. »
Au contraire, chacun d'entre nous est précieux.
Chacun d'entre nous est irremplaçable aux yeux de Dieu.
Dans les ténèbres des conflits actuels,
chacun d'entre nous peut devenir un cierge éblouissant,
une preuve que la lumière peut vaincre les ténèbres,
et jamais l'inverse.
Pour les Chrétiens, le futur a un nom,
et ce nom est l'Espérance.
Espérer ne veut pas dire être un optimiste naïf
et ignorer la tragédie que vit l'humanité.
L'Espérance est la vertu d'un cœur
qui ne s'enferme pas dans les ténèbres, qui ne demeure pas dans le passé,
qui ne fait pas que passer dans le présent,
mais qui est capable de voir des lendemains.
L'Espérance est la porte qui mène vers l'avenir.
L'Espérance est une graine de vie, cachée, humble,
qui, avec le temps, deviendra un arbre immense.
Elle est comme un levain invisible qui permet à toute la pâte de lever,
qui donne du goût à tous les aspects de la vie.
Elle peut accomplir tellement,
car une petite lueur vacillante qui se nourrit d'espérance
suffit à détruire le bouclier des ténèbres.
Un seul individu suffit à faire vivre l'espérance
et cet individu peut être vous.
Et ensuite, il y en aura un autre, et encore un autre,
jusqu'à ce que cela devienne un « nous ».
Est-ce que l'espérance commence quand nous sommes un « nous » ?
Non.
Elle commence avec une seule personne.
Quand il y a un « nous », c'est une révolution qui commence.
Le troisième message que je voudrais partager avec vous aujourd'hui
parle en fait de révolution : la révolution de la tendresse.
Qu'est-ce que la tendresse ?
C'est l'amour qui se rapproche et se concrétise.
C'est un mouvement qui part du cœur
et arrive aux yeux, aux oreilles et aux mains.
La tendresse nous demande de nous servir de nos yeux pour voir l'autre,
de nos oreilles pour l'écouter,
pour écouter les enfants, les pauvres, ceux qui ont peur de l'avenir ;
pour entendre le cri silencieux de notre maison commune,
notre Terre polluée et malade.
La tendresse nous demande de nous servir de nos mains et de notre cœur
pour réconforter l'autre,
pour prendre soin de ceux dans le besoin.
La tendresse est le langage des jeunes enfants,
de ceux qui ont besoin de l'autre.
L'amour d'un enfant pour son père et sa mère
grandit grâce au toucher, au regard, à la voix, à la tendresse.
J'adore écouter des parents
parler à leur bébé,
s'adapter au petit enfant, partager le même niveau de communication.
C'est ça la tendresse : se mettre au niveau de l'autre.
Dieu est descendu en Jésus pour être à notre niveau.
C'est le chemin que le Bon Samaritain a suivi.
C'est le chemin que Jésus lui-même a pris.
Il s'est abaissé,
il a vécu toute son existence humaine
à parler le langage vrai, le langage concret de l'amour.
Oui, la tendresse est le chemin à suivre
par les femmes et les hommes les plus forts et les plus courageux.
La tendresse n'est pas une faiblesse mais une force.
C'est le chemin de la solidarité, le chemin de l'humilité.
Permettez-moi de le clamer haut et fort :
plus vous êtes puissant,
plus vos actions auront des conséquences sur les hommes,
plus vous devrez agir avec humilité.
Si vous ne le faites pas, votre pouvoir vous détruira, vous, mais aussi l'autre.
Il y a un proverbe en Argentine :
« le pouvoir agit sur l'homme comme l'alcool sur un estomac vide. »
La tête vous tourne, vous êtes saoul, vous perdez l'équilibre
et vous finissez par vous faire mal et faire mal aux autres,
si vous ne reliez pas votre pouvoir à l'humilité et à la tendresse.
A l'inverse, grâce à l'humilité et à l'amour authentique,
le pouvoir - le plus noble, le plus fort - se met au service du bien.
L'avenir de l'humanité n'est pas seulement entre les mains des politiciens,
des grands dirigeants, des grandes sociétés.
Certes, ils possèdent une immense responsabilité.
Mais l'avenir, avant tout, est entre les mains des hommes
qui reconnaissent l'autre comme un individu,
et eux-mêmes comme un élément du « nous ».
Nous avons tous besoin de l'autre.
Et je vous prie de me voir, moi aussi, avec tendresse,
afin que je puisse accomplir la tâche que l'on m'a confiée
pour le bien d'autrui,
pour le bien de chacun, de vous tous,
de nous tous.
Merci.